what are you most excited about for your
company and the industry in general oh
that's that's an awesome question um
look i i like i mentioned i'm a tradfi
guy i was
literally um a gold ceo and and my view
was like gold is going to the moon i
have a masters in economics i started my
phd in economics
you know what the u.s is doing in terms
of fiat money printing and basically the
destruction of the value of the us
dollar is just bonkers to me
but you know it is what it is it's not
going to change and and so now you have
this sector
and this is where i'm getting directly
to your question um this is maybe the
most exciting investment opportunity
our generation your generation you know
many generations will see
it it's it's the chance to go back to
1994 and buy you know 10 20 100 grand of
of amazon at pennies to where it's
trading at now so the most exciting
thing for me is is just going from this
sort of staid
relatively boring sector called gold um
into
you know an industry where i get to talk
to the likes of you guys i mean like
it's an honor being on this podcast and
and having the background i have and yet
getting
to to to see people who have just so
much interest in making things better
and sort of disintermediating um this
this this global banking system that has
just made gazillions you know and and so
to be a part of of changing the entire
financial ecosystem is is you know
beyond uh exciting so it's it's just
every day picking up the phone talking
to people like you talking to investors
looking at new protocols looking at what
like you know ave is doing in the
lending world um you know looking at
what's happening in the metaverse you
know we're about to launch a metaverse
gaming basket and my
you know i would have thought
a year ago that our bitcoin and ethereum
baskets etps would have been like like
like the growth market for the company
but i have a feeling that the metaverse
gaming basket is is going to be our top
performing uh etp so
this is changing every day you guys must
see like like people like me uh you know
geniuses who created some of these
protocols who are now billionaires um
it's just it's changing it's so exciting
uh it's so
interesting being being able to do this
on a listed market as well
um yeah so it's it's just basically
putting all of it together and just
being involved in in such a
transformative industry russell you guys
are in the process of launching a number
of these etps um yeah one talk about
what your ideas there are but also to
explain like why the public market
structure for those types of uh
properties are uh so advantageous in
your opinion and who are the types of
investors that you anticipate buying
that stuff versus maybe participating in
the private market uh you know aspect of
this industry yeah so
you know as i was remarking before
i mean clearly bitcoin adoption is going
up clearly ethereum adoption is going up
clearly the tbl in all of these d5
protocols is going up um
but but even with that in context
literally the majority of the world
can't or isn't comfortable with opening
up the these unusual trading accounts
that you have to do for for a coin base
or kraken or whatever so so the real
value proposition for us is is like
bringing a protocol like selena or polka
dot or um anthony to answer your
question like we're going to be
launching top 10 d5 top 10 defy yield
we're just finalizing basically baskets
which is going to be something new so
it's almost like a it's almost like a
diversified etf that people can actually
invest in and get get exposure to you
know gaming and metaverse all in one and
then top 10 d5 all in one top 10 d5
yield all in one um and so it's it's
it's it's taking
you know solana that i think
everybody should have in their portfolio
taking ethereum that everyone should
have in their portfolio and just
simplifying it for the investors so that
they can actually buy it on a listed
regulated exchange through you know
the your us example would be like
through your your charles schwab or your
td ameritrade account um just just that
in europe so you're actually you're
actually opening the doors even more
for these nascent protocols to be
adopted um and and understood by by the
general investing public which
you know is the biggest market in the
world and then in terms of conversations
that you have with a lot of these
institutional type investors or people
who are interested in public market
companies what's been the general tone
and how has that changed over the last
year or so as you've been having those
conversations it's literally being um
incredible because
um even institutions like like i i grew
up as an nc sales guy right um
institutional trading ultimately
corporate finance then created my own
broker dealer actually in canada that's
that's become a really
big player in the canadian capital
markets um
this is
um
so
innovative so transformative so
um
crazy because the institutions when they
first create their their fun pros uh
prospectuses or they're offering them
randoms they basically state where they
can invest and and none of them 10 years
ago thought that you know coinbase was
even going to exist other than a few
really really
very risk-taking and opportunistic
and smart people who created it and so
now what you're seeing is institutions
saying how do i get long
bitcoin without
being able to open an account on
coinbase or on kraken how do i get long
ethereum how do i get law and selena and
so
you know
you're seeing hedge funds that pop up
that invest on all these alternative
trading exchanges but then you also have
you know the biggest part of that
investing community that can't and so
having them
them being able to see and invest into a
salana
or even just defy the parent company
like we had an institution uh
offshore that basically called us one
day and just was like we're gonna buy
2.5 million shares because they actually
see this as a way of getting long
without having
to effectively go to all their
shareholders or go to all of their
creators of their funds or their hedge
fund committees to actually rewrite
their offering memorandum or their
prospectus to allow them to start
investing on these alternative exchanges
they can now do it through us and i i
think honestly that's going to be a real
dominant theme you saw in vesco i think
it was you guys who actually tweeted it
invesco
is starting to launch uh d5 protocol um
etps etfs um you know the the the
market's gonna get crowded so to speak
but if you're looking at a market that's
growing two times faster than the
internet i don't care how many people
get involved um you know today tomorrow
it's not going to be able to keep up
with the demand that you're going to see
from the traditional
equity investor basically jumping on
board to all these protocols